wichtiger wie auch dringender beschluss
darüber wie es in der korona pandemie
weiter gehen soll
diese ergänzung heißt auf den
wichtigsten nenner gebracht wir setzen
die notbremse bundesweit um wo die
inzidenz über 100 liegt sollen künftig
bundeseinheitliche regelungen gelten die
notbremse ist da nicht mehr
auslegungssache sondern sie greift
automatisch die unklarheiten was in dem
einen oder anderen landkreis wann gilt
oder was war nicht gilt das ist dann
vorbei dort wo die zahl der infektionen
stabil unterhalb der inzidenz von 100
ist sind es weiterhin die länder die in
ihren verordnungen über einschränkungen
genauso wie über lockerungen entscheiden
die bundeseinheitlich geltenden
notbremse ist überfällig denn auch wenn
es schwer fällt das auch heute wieder zu
hören
die lage ist ernst und wir alle müssen
sie auch ernst nehmen
die dritte welle der pandemie hat unser
land fest im griff
das sagen die täglichen infektionszahlen
des robert koch instituts das sagt die
entwicklung des erwerbs und das sagen
vor allem die zahlen der belegten
intensivbetten ich habe von beginn an
immer gesagt wenn wir warten würden bis
alle intensivbetten belegt sind dann
wäre es zu spät das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
und wir dürfen auch die hilferufe der
intensivmediziner nicht überhören
wir dürfen die ärzte und pfleger die
seit über einem jahr in den
krankenhäusern alles geben um sich gegen
die erste gegen die zweite und jetzt
auch gegen die dritte welle zu stemmen
nicht alleine mit dieser herkulesaufgabe
lassen
wir dürfen sie nicht im stich lassen wir
müssen ihnen helfen denn ohne unsere
unterstützung die vom staat politik von
allen bürgerinnen und bürgern können sie
den kampf gegen das virus auch mit
bester medizinischer kunst
und dem aufopferungsvollen einsatz nicht
gewinnen sie brauchen uns und damit das
besser wird damit für die dritte welle
bremsen damit wir sie brechen damit wir
sie umkehren
reichen die bisherigen bodtländer
beratung alleine nicht mehr aus sondern
muss unsere pandemie bekämpfung
stringenter konsequenter werden
wir müssen die dritte welle der pandemie
bremsen und den rapiden anstieg der
infektionen stoppen
außerdem verstehen die bürgerinnen und
bürger regionale unterschiede sehr wohl
aber sie erwarten nachvollziehbarkeit
und klarheit deshalb davon bin ich
überzeugt ist es im wortsinne notwendig
unsere zusammenarbeit auf neue füße zu
stellen
und genau das geschieht mit dem heute
eingeleiteten gesetzgebungsverfahren ich
bin mir ganz bewusst dass es harte
einschränkungen sind die das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz insbesondere für
kreise oberhalb der inzidenz 100
vorsieht
kontakt beschränkungen schließungen von
geschäften kultur und sporteinrichtungen
nächtliche ausgangssperren alle diesen
maßnahmen im übrigen auch ein heute
beschlossenes verpflichtendes test
angebot der arbeitgeber für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
dienen einem einzigen ziel dem ziel
unser ganzes land aus dieser phase der
stetig steigenden infektionszahlen der
sich füllenden intensivstationen und der
bestürzenden täglichen zahl der korona
toten herauszuführen
wir haben es ja schon einmal geschafft
durch konsequentes handeln die zahl der
ansteckung wieder auf ein
kontrollierbares maß zu reduzieren und
das kann und wird uns auch wieder
gelingen da eines hilft uns dabei
natürlich enorm während wir noch uns
noch einmal auf diese entbehrungen und
freiheitsbeschränkungen einstellen läuft
ja die impfkampagne
und sie läuft jeden tag besser tag für
tag werden hunderttausende mit den
besten schutz gegen die krankheit
versehen
und seit die hautärzte einbezogen
und auch die betriebsärzte werden noch
hinzukommen gehen wir dem licht am ende
des tunnels mit immer größeren schritten
entgegen und daher möchte ich auch heute
den bürgerinnen und bürgern danken für
ihre geduld ihre einsicht ihre fürsorge
für andere und unser führte und dafür
dass unser ganzes land auch nach dieser
langen zeit gut durch die krise kommt
wir werden den heutigen beschluss nun
den fraktionen von cdu csu und spd als
sogenannte formulierungshilfe zur
verfügung stellen
ich danke auch den kolleginnen und
kollegen der opposition für ihre
kritisch konstruktive mitarbeit und
freue mich auf gute und zügige beratung
im deutschen bundestag damit uns dieses
wichtige gesetz sehr bald schon helfen
kann
die pandemie zu besiegt herzlichen dank
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben die lage
auf den intensivstationen angesprochen
und auch den fahrplan jetzt nun heißt es
eine fraktion sei gegen die
fristverkürzung im bundestag und im
verfahren kommt die notbremse wenn
möglicherweise der bundesrat erst ende
nächster woche abstimmt und zweite
dritte lesung auch nächste woche ist ist
das nicht zu spät für die notbremse
angesichts der dramatischen situation
die sie geschildert haben und geht es da
schon sehr viel im wahlkampf auch danke
nein also ich glaube es gibt sehr
konstruktive debatten unter den
fraktionen sie wissen für beschleunigung
braucht man zwei drittel mehrheiten im
verfahren und die geschäftsführer werden
jetzt darüber beraten ich kann aus
meiner perspektive nur sagen dass je
schneller es geht umso besser dass
natürlich ist sowohl im bundestag als
auch dann im bundesrat
frau bundeskanzlerin sie wollten sich ja
eigentlich raushalten auch als cdu
politikerin aus dem aus der suche für
ihre nachfolge
jetzt stehen sie so ein bisschen oder
ziemlich sogar zwischen herrn laschet
und herrn söder
fürchten sie dass diese anhaltende
wettkampf am ende dazu führen kann dass
für die union das die union wirklich
schaden nimmt und am ende das kanzleramt
verloren gehen könnte
sie haben es ja schon richtig gesagt
ich wollte will und werde mich da
heraushalten dankeschön